What was that?
So Kaimon? Is that now the name of that ship that we're all sailing on into TVD-land?
Um, how's everybody doing this morning?
Excellent!
My name is Jarett Wieselman
And I have been covering this show for six years
I've met a lot of you, I've tweeted with more of you
And it's safe to say there is no more dedicated fandom than the Vampire Diaries fandom.
You guys wait in line, and because of your intense devotion, we are in Hall H, for the very first time.
So, are you guys ready for the biggest Vampire Diaries panel ever?
Well, let's get it started, first up: star Michael Malarkey
The lovely Candice Accola
One half of all of our new favorite ships: Ian Somerhalder
Executive producer Julie Plec
Paul Wesley
Executive producer Caroline Dries
And last, but by no means least: Kat Graham
Guys, give it up for the cast of The Vampire Diaries!
I'm down there!
Are we aloud to sit?
It must be very early, it's extremely quiet in here!
You guys gonna make s-
How many of you guys slept over last night?
Paul, let me go to you first, I'm curious,
Back when Vampire Diaries actually featured diaries, did you ever envision that six years later
you would be surrounded by five thousand of your closest fans in the biggest Comic Con ballroom there is?
Um, I...
I...
Wait, what does that have to do with diaries?
You used to write in diaries, it's fine, we can move on
I just feel like when i wanna hear the fans go wild, I just need to say two words
Jared & Jensen
Don't worry, they're coming up, they're coming up, they're coming up
Now, what was your question?
What does it mean to see all of these people here, for the show that you guys worked so hard on?
Oh, no, honestly guys, it's amazing
This is the first time at Hall H, I can't see the end of the room
I'm slightly intimidated
That's 'cause you're drunk
Um, i am also drunk
I haven't slept, um, it means a lot, I know you guys woke up early, and I can speak on behalf of all of us
We really appreciate it and, we love you guys
So, that's the truth
Thank you!
Julie, it's been a very long journey, you've all been on in Hall H
Is it in any way bitter sweet that, you know, someone is missing, who helped put the show on the map?
Yeah, of course it's bitter, Jesus I can't talk
Who?
Yeah, what do you mean, no, of course
Jesus!
And, okay
Of course it's bitter sweet, we miss Nina, she's been with us for six years,
Uh, we miss Kevin, he's been with us for all that time too
and both they're up back home in LA
And hopefully sending us good love from home
Absolutely
The sleeping curse I think was a really interesting way to sort of tie up that storyline
As a storyteller, what excites you about the opportunities afforded to you
by having her sort of gone but not forgotten?
Well, what's nice about it is there's still an intense core of romance, almost like in a fairytale way attached to it
Damon, you know, has put the love of his life away
And now he's got to figure out how-
She's just taking a little nap
a sixty-seven-year-nap
Yeah, what's sixty-seven years for a vampire? It'll go by like that
You know
By the way, I have no problem playing a 17-year old in my mid-sixties
If I'm pulling it off at thirty-two
Guys, you know
What do you think?
You don't look a day over fourty, Paul
You don't look a day over fourty, buddy
That's what they tell me
So, I'm curious, Caroline
With Bonnie and Elena sort of linked now, does the lovely Kat Graham have the best job security
on this death crowned show?
Uh, Bonnie dies like every season, so
Yeah, it's like nine lives, I'm not sure, we're probably at six, maybe now
Five or six
Yeah, she's got at least three seasons left in her
Nice
I like it
Kat, what was your reaction when you found out how Bonnie would play into
the sleeping beauty curse for Elena?
You know, it's very interesting because I, obviously I've known that Nina was leaving for a long time
Um, but I thought it was a really clever way to, um, kind of keep Elena there
And keep her presence there, um, and keep the door open in a lot of ways for her to be able to come back
But it also created an interesting dynamic going into season seven for Bonnie and Damon
and them to have to deal with the fact that, you know, Bonnie is alive and Elena's not
and it's kind of on Bonnie
to stay alive
But it felt super earned, you know, by having Damon and Bonnie in the nineties together for so long
It was such a rich relationship by the time we got to the finale
I mean for both of you, what did you like about how that relationship sort of flourished last season?
I was actually, I don't know
That was my favorite stuff that we've ever done
yes
I think the beginning of season six for Bonnie and Damon was the best stuff ever
What do you think?
Uh, it was a lot of fun and it was very dynamic and
these two people, you know, it's funny because
they hate each other
they love each other
they resent each other, they're stuck together
it's sort of an amazing recipe for a lot of cool drama
yeah
But Kat and I love to work together, because we work together with the same coach
in the same way and we have a lot of really good fun
Yeah, one of my favorite episodes is the episode that Ian directed
And it was actually the first time that I'd ever been in a scene where the director is also the actor
So we had some really cool stuff and I'm excited that Ian
You're directing again in season seven, right?
Is that the plan?
Well, um, yeah, hopefully
okay
yes absolutely!
Sorry! I didn't know, I don't know, I don't know!
Yes, we're gonna do it again
I don't know, but yeah, we had a lot of fun
It was really great for us to shoot some scenes together
and definitely when I got to come back it was great that one of my first scenes was definitely with Ian, it was great
Julie, talk a little bit about sort of Damon post Elena sleeping beauty curse
I mean, is he a munk now?
Or do you just like
yeah
Munk my ass!
You just put that energy in sort of different areas of that character
I'm waiting for Ian to make an inappropriate  about putting that energy in other places
Just wait for it
Um, yeah, no, i mean the challenge for Damon is obviously, Elena said to him
please, live your life, and be who you are
We know who Damon is
So, I think for him it's who am I, without this girl right by my side?
'Cause she's the center, she's the one that grounds me
and makes me want to make the right decision and walk the straight line
So, for him, the line is gonna get a little crooked, you know
and he's gonna kinda probably hopscotch over it
'cause, I know he loved Elena
Hopscotch?
So, he'll, you know, the struggle will be good, we'll get to see a lot of naughty Damon
trying to not be naughty
I love hopscotch
Ian, what, I mean in some ways it's sort of like you're playing a new Damon this year
that has to be exciting?
or an old Damon
Actually au contraitre, mon frère
It's actually the exact opposite
It's actually the opposite
It's the old fucking Damon
The Damon that we really fell in love with
and that's the goal, it's that
you know, let's bring that back
that energy, that sexy, fun, scary, dangerous...
All that shit that made you guys love him to begin with
I'm bringing it back!
Caroline, as writers
What excites you guys about getting back to the root of Damon?
Well, it's interesting, you know
We've seen Damon, pining for Katherine,
for a hundred and forty-five years
Then he was pining for Elena
you know, seasons two through six
so
it's fun for us as writers to think, who is Damon Salvatore when he's not pining after a girl?
When he has his girl
And, so it's interesting, I was just talking to Ian the other day
Like, what does Damon do in his spare time?
Like, what does he do when he's alone
and, I
I...
I'm still waiting for Ian and Paul to make an inappropriate joke
What else does he do when he's alone?
So, um
Oh my
a lot of stuff
So it's fun for writers to kinda get to dig a little deeper into the character
And figure out, like, you know, what makes him tick, and we're gonna see a lot of
bromance between Stefan and Damon
And see how the dynamic works, now that their mom is kind of becoming part of Mystic Falls
absolutely
as sort of Delena moved into a crypt, as you were
there was the rising of another relationship
on The Vampire Diaries
one that goes by the name of Steroline
By the way can we change that
Doesn't it sound-
By the way, guys
No, I was gonna say, doesn't it sound so clean?
Sounds like something in a hospital
We're actually gonna make a hand sanitizer called Steroline
We're gonna-, we trademarked it and sell it at Hall H
Paul, can you guys come up with a different name though?
Dude, you got, you're like, what are you, Delena?
Like that's any better?
Or Bamon?
At least it doesn't sound like it's in a hospital
Delena sounds like it could potentially be a disease
Steroline sounds like the cure for the disease
Wauw
That was
That was actually good and witty
Well, I...
Did you just come up with that right now?
I'm impressed
Was that like on the spot?
Yeah it was
It's not like I thought of this last night or anything
You weren't staying up thinking about what you were gonna say?
I can't wait to pull that one out
Paul for a lot of fans this relationship has been a long time coming
What excites you about seeing it come to fruition?
I just love making Candice feel awkward
on the set
um
candice is married
I'm friends with her husband
um
I love when we have to do make out scenes
Because it's so uncomfortable
um
and so funny
and
um
But you-, we love each other, don't we love each other?
oh, yeah
Don't you love me? Don' t you just love me?
Just so much
Yeah!
What are we-, no honestly, it's, if I'm gonna answer the question sincerely
I personally, my opinion is, I do like the fact that there is so much history between these two characters
It obviously was very platonic
It was that little, kind of those little moments, those moments were you sort of zoom in on the eyes
and there's something going on
It could happen between anyone
I feel like Ian and I have had those moments
But, you know, it's been a-, yeah, right?
There's a couple of shippers there
that's what I'm talking about
You know, I am my brothers keeper
Based on that
There it is
why cross the street when you can cross a hall?
So hey!
relax
I taught him that one, by the way
You did
In more ways than one
So, what are we doing here?
Um, anyway, I really like Steroline
What do you think, Candice?
Oh, well, after that
No, in all seriousness, I love a good
slow-burning relationship in a televisionseries, where you get to watch build
and, um
I really like the characters together
So I'm excited to see what happens in season seven, the few scripts that we have read
I'm really excited for you guys to see
And I don't wanna say anything else, otherwise I'll get in trouble for spoilers, but
That's okay
Well, before we look ahead, I wanna keep talking, Candice, about Caroline this season
When she turned her humanity off
Because
That was one of my absolute favorite things that has ever been on The Vampire Diaries
handsdown
That ark, watching you go from the devastation
to the complete
ripping people's throats out to like
falling against Stefan, against
sodamachines
and making out, like it was al very
It was al wonderful
What did you-
If you wanna ever try something really disturbing
Put a lot of fake blood in your mouth and have to make out with someone else
It definitely
I'm glad it al worked out on television
But that was definitely an awkward day at work
I mean, over the years, you've taken her to such different extremes
You know, from human, to vampire, now to this
What excited you about what you got to play
Through that humanity free version of this character this year?
Um, it was really fun!
You know, it was such a tragicstoryline
And i kind of knew, or was clued in that sheriff Forbes was going to pass this season
and how it was going to happen and I thought it was just such a human, you know, obstacle
That these characters hadn't really faced
And there was no supernatural spell that could break the fact that she had cancer, and I thought that was really powerful
So, from all that grief, and all that sadness
You just go from, you know, heartless, badass Caroline
And that was really, really fun
and a really cool change for the character
Don't you love the fact that like
Caroline has like murdered and like
done all this crazy shit and now she's like gonna be like
probably planning a dance and like
episode eight, she's gonna be like
coordinating
She's a multitasker
it's really amazing!
It's a lot done, at all times
we're all sociopathic murderers
Julie, when you, you know, we look ahead
for this couple
What can you sort of tease about
What lies in store for them in season seven?
a lot of very unexpected twists and turns actually
what the fun of this couple is
that they're just coming together
they're just getting really cemented in the romantic status  and so
you know, that's where we left it off, you had sort of said "I will be here when you're ready"
and so she's trying really really really
really hard not to be ready
um
but
she can't resist
shirtless Stef
every episode
that's not gonna happen
a lot-, I think, yeah, more sh-
Do you guys want more shirtless scenes from Stefan?
Oh no!
I think this is a formal request
That was season one, when I was a youngster
you guys
Times have changed
Well, in this show's grand tradition of like semi-disfunctional relationships
they would be remissed if i didn't talk about Enzo and Lily
and whatever is happening there
Uh, Michael
Are you gonna bone our mom?
Oh my God!
Let's just get it out on the table
morning everyone!
she'd be Enzo's first
no, It's a joke
this is some of my character research coming out
no, carry on
Enzo definitely got to sort of be a part of a lot of the action this year
in terms of propelling the story forward, with Lily
And what she brought to Mystic Falls
What excites you about sort of his role in all of that
more screen time
I'm playing
No, I'm not
Yes, I am
um
Um, I love the fact that there's a really kind of
succinct dilemma for Enzo this season
Which is about choosing his allegiance
and
um
You know, does he go with Lily and the heretics, or does he go with Damon or
hang out with this chick
You  know
and um
I think it's a very clear struggle for him
and uh
It's going to be interesting to see where
where it goes
absolutely
I'm gonna open it up for fan questions in a minute, 'cause I know you guys have a lot of them
So I think there's a line there, and there
But before I do that
Julie and Caroline, working of what he just said
What can you sort of tease about the heretics
and season seven, and sort of what the fans in this room can expect?
when the show comes back
Oh, well, the challenge for the writers season seven is constantly topping the villain from the previous year
and we thought Kai was one of the best villains we've ever had on the show
And so we were thinking, you know, how
do we do that?
and so by bringing in Lily's family
it's these six
Villains who can do magic, and they're vampires
and it's the first time we ever see our characters
try, you know, to go up against them
And just kind of react and be like, oh, like, we don't know what we're doing
Like, this is very very hard
So, I think it's gonna be really kind of exciting and
grusome and violent when we start
But the real mystery will be: how did Mystic Falls get to be the way we saw it at the end of season six?
which is runned down
and
um
You know, polluted and borded up
so
there are some really great new characters, three women especially
Valerie, who we have just casted this weekend and
we'll anounce, as soon as our deal closes
and
and then a new couple: Nora and Mary-Louise
who have been together for
what? about hundred and twenty years i think? so...
It's gonna be fun
they're nasty, nasty, nasty girls
but
they're gonna be good
Yeah!
nasty girls!
here it is
nice
Well, let's turn it over to you guys
I've talked plenty
We're gonna go to our first fan question, right over here
Hello!
Hi!
Khaleesi!
Yeah that's me
Yeah that's me!
What's your question?
Um my question is for Ian
It's a big room, be nice to me guys
Will you marry me?
She's the mother of dragons Ian
I don't think I can
I'm a happily married man
I understand
But...
You can always move to Utah
Paul, we're no longer married
Who?
But I'm sure if you asked anyone else
They'd be all over it
Have an amazing amazing Con!
Thank you so much
Next question
Great question by the way
Hi
Hi!
Um, I have a question for Ian
Oh shit
Will you marry me?
If Damon
If season-six-Damon could give
season-one-Damon advice, what would it be?
Never change
Um
Well
Look
This guy
makes a lot of bad decisions all the time
and I think after
Being a hundred and seventy-four years old
You would probably think to start
thinking before you act
and do things
which he doesn't
Which is why we kind of love the guy
So if season-six-Damon could actually talk to
season-one-Damon
I think season-six-Damon would say...
Hey man...
Remind me how i used to be
And take me back to that place
So never change
Never change
Awesome
Thank you!
Next question
Hi, my name is Catherine
I'm nicer than Katherine
Prove it!
I just look nice, alright
Okay
So my question is for the two hottest brothers
uhm
How did you capture the mentality of a 17-year old  teenager
Or a 24-year old young adult
When you're actually...
old?
No! No, no, no, no!
How much is 15 years?
I...
I mean...
I don't like to...
I can't really speak subjectively
But I can speak objectively, looking at Ian
That he has the mentality of a 12-year old
so...
He...
For him the challenge was playing a 17-year old
The maturity
He had to actually
learn how to mature
uhm
and, uh...
absolutely
that's acting
and I
I think you did an okay job
uhm
yeah
Ian?
Some of the smartest people in the world
are twelve, Paul
Listen
We were fortunate enough
to be able to play these characters
Stefan had the earnest capabilities
the beauty-, like the beautiful
soft side of a 17-year old
But also, two, the same type of angst and confusion
And Damon was
It's like arrested development
Damon was 23
You know
Not the tv-show guys!
arrested development
great show though, great show
as in meaning his development was stopped!
uh, at 23
But he didn't learn that much
uhm...
it was very cool, actually, being able to play these guys
But the reality of it is, is that
look
We still act like kids
and we will forever act like kids
And the day any of us stop acting like kids
It is no bueno
and guys...
They make some really-
I mean, we live in 2015
and there's some great moisturizers out there!
and...
two words
sun block
We apply them
daily
it's a great question though, actually
thank you
it is a good question
sorry for being an idiot
Hi, what's your question
Hi, my name is Ashley
and, uh, my question is for Paul and Candice
A few seasons back
Klaus vouched his love for Caroline
Could we expect him to come back
and fight for her, now that we have...
He's gonna have to get trough me, babe
And he'll probably kick my ass
I don't know if Caroline really wants him back in Mystic Falls
Oooh, you heard it!
But that's a question for Julie
You heard it here, folks
Julie and Caroline
Oh, I'm not going there
okay
Thank you very much
Hi
they're here
That felt flat
moving on
Can we hear you?
Hello
hello
There you are!
Oh, hi guys!
Um, so my name is Courtney
my favorite episode
Hi courtney
My favorite episode is 'Lost girls'
Me too!
'Cause Damon's dancing shirtless
Am i right ladies?
yes!
It's a good episode
I wondered what your guys' favorite episode is
Well, mine is lost girls
Yeah, mine is lost girls
Paul just likes to see me dancing half naked
I also think the most brilliant episodes are the ones
that I direct
I don't know why
That's just
Lost girls, honestly, for me, and
Julie and I have had this conversation a million times
encapsulated
What that
season one
Vampire Diaries was
It was fun
It was sexy
It was vollidle
It was Kayla Ewell running around for five days
in her underwear
It was us, drinking from each others wrists
Being drunk in blood and happiness
and decadence and fun
and
that was that smarmy, awesome
fun stuff, that we are bringing back, so...
But wasn't that also the flashback episodes, lost girls?
yeah
It was the first flashback wasn't it?
Yeah, it was the first time we did flashbacks
First time we saw Katherine
First time we saw...
Yeah, I love-
I thought-, I mean I think the flashback episodes on
Vampire Diaries are the most powerful episodes
What do you guys think?
Yeah
What are your favorites?
For sentimental reasons, the pilot
But that's just
because I'm being sentimental
Stop being sentimental
I know
I don't have a cool answer
Malarkey's actually never seen an episode
Yeah
I just started watching the show
since I'm in it
No, I'm just playing
I-, you know what, I really liked the hundredth episode
I thought that was a pretty banging episode
yeah
Kat
Oh, uhm
eh
season three, episode five
the reckoning
oh yeah
That's my favorite episode, I mean-
Which one?
The reckoning
ah!
ehm
That was actually when Bonnie had lost her powers
think it was like one of the first times
she'd lost her powers
And, eh...
She went in-,  we had a scene with
She had a scene with Matt
Bonnie had a scene with Matt Donovan
And he had strapped weights onto himself
And that, he actually did
And he was actually at the bottom of the pool
And I had to dive in, 'cause Bonnie
couldn't use her magic
There was nothing she had to rely on
You know
kind of
the character had to rely on what she was made of
So I love that about her
And it was kind of one of the first times
I got to see the character really
She became I think a hero for herself
Because she didn't have any
magic, she couldn't use magic as a crutch
She had to go in and just do the human thing
and, to save his life
So that was cool when we got to
dive in fully clothed and pull up Zach Roerig
which was totally light
totally easy to do
It was great
awesome
thank you for your question
thank you
Guys, are you having fun?
They're warming up
Okay, I was just checking
Are you guys cold? It's cold in here
It's cold and it's Sunday morning
But you're having fun, that's good
Sorry
What is your guys' plan for after Vampire Diaries?
You're like-, they're like "We're on tv!'
Sorry, what was the question?
Oh, what is your guys' plan for after Vampire Diaries?
It's never ending
I'm gonna sink into a deep depression
ehm
Stare at Ian Somerhalders headshots
Try to get another job
What are you gonna do Ian?
Guys
I thought-, I was told this was never ending?
That's true
Is it?
Isn't this never ending?
I tell you what
Ask us that next year
Maybe
We're just trying to survive now
Actually, I'm gonna get on
one of Julies other nine shows
I wouldn't worry, we have a great relationship
You'll hire me
No, no
Done!
Kat-, Kat and I will go do a show
Yeah, we could go do a show
Love it
Alright, thank you for your question
Hi
Thank you guys so much for being here
So my question is
At the end of season five, the other side vanished
along with the people inside it
What happens now to the supernatural creatures
that die in the series?
Dunzo
Julie?
dead?
Caroline?
Well
We did that on purpose so death meant something
So now if they die they die
And they go to one of Julie Plecs other shows
yeah
also true
Which I think is a solid way to do it
You die, you die
logical
If he dies, he dies
He dies, he dies
Here's a reference
Thank you for your question
Pulling a little rocky reference there, Paul
I like it
Hi, how are you?
Hello, I'm Ashley
Good morning, guys
Morning
My question is for Paul
Just wanted to let you know
I've loved you since season 1
But
I wanted to know if you and your character
Have, like, similar characteristics in real life?
No
What do you mean no?
Stefan's like all lovely
Stefan's so sweet though
Charismatic, positive...
Hair fanatic
Doesn't complain about dancing
The hair is similar
That's what I was gonna say!
The hair is very similar
Loves decade dances
Thank you for loving me since season one
That's-
I just would like to address that
I...
Literally have nothing in common with Stefan
Therefor you probably wouldn't like me in real life
But...
I do my own hair
And I feel really good about it
Thank you, thank you, thank you
That deserves a round of applause
And I-, look
I cry over women a lot
And Stefan is constantly crying over women
And I constantly cry over women
So that's what I have in common
I'm about to start crying over you, right now
That's good
yeah
Thank you for your question
Hi
My name is Valerie
Paul, I'm glad you comb your own hair
Thank you
My question's for Julie
You came back off of Ians answer
Do you foresee the show ending next season?
And if so, do you know how it will end?
Oooh
We're all like hmmm
This better be good
I'm like, I don't even know how to answer this
No, I actually do not foresee the show ending after next season
I think that-
I think that we've got a more story to tell and
I think that we've built this kind of gorgeous family
That I'm not quite ready to split up yet, so
You know, circumstances and other things may intervene, but
But as far as I'm concerned
We've got lots of stuff to-
However
Can I just ask you a question?
If it were to end, how would it end?
Oh
I know how it ends
Ooh, she knows how it ends, folks
I know how it ends, Caroline knows how it ends
And no matter what happens between now and when
it ends, I believe it will remain ending that way, so
Oh yeah
okay
Thank you
Hi
Who's got the truth serum guys?
Hi!
I'm Taylor
Hey Taylor
Hi
Okay, so
Oh my God
This screen is so big
okay
Holy shit!
She's not lying
It's very big
It's the truth
Okay, so my question is basically
In, or at the end of season 5, when Katherine
took the cure, and then
Or got forced the cure
And in season 6 she, like, her death
progressed really quickly
Why is Damon planning on taking the cure
With Elena
And planning on, like,  having a long
extended life, if that's just gonna happen to him?
Katherine didn't start to disintegrate until
Silas took it from her
So you can be a carrier of the cure
Yeah, once the cure is sucked out of you
That's when you start to disintegrate
I don't know why you can't follow these very easy rules
Then you can use Steroline to fix
the cure
I can't hear you
I can't hear you either
I have no idea what you guys are talking about
We can't hear anything up here by the way
We literally can't hear anything
I just hear laughter, it's gotta be great
Thank you for your question
Can you guys hear us back there?
No
Holy cow!
Wauw, it goes really far back
Okay, I just want you guys to know that we love you
I didn't know it went that far back!
I haven't really been able to see you or hear you, so...
Wow!
We love you
Hey, how's it going?
That goes far back
That's amazing!
Hi
Hey!
How's it going, guys?
Hello
What's up man?
Not much, you guys enjoying Comic Con?
Yeah
clearly
What have you checked out since you've been here?
I checked out Paul
I checked out Ian checking himself out
Oh yeah
As in like, the...-
We lost you, buddy
We lost your mic
We've had like no time
We spent the entire day yesterday, literally bouncing
from interview to interview
And taking silly photos
And all that stuff
Did we have any good, like, party interactions with other actors, or anything?
Ooh! I met uhm-
We both did!
Christian Slater and Rami Malek last night, from Mr Robot
yes
And I geeked over them like a fangirl for five minutes!
Like a stalker
Julie and I had a fangirl moment together last night
Where I told her that I had met uhm...
Rami and Christian
I physically grabbed him!
yes
I did!
I was like: 'You're spectacular!'
'Your show is spectacular!'
And then I went on and on and he just stared
at me like 'Oh my God, what's happening?'
security
It's my favorite show right now
so we geek out too, that's why I can't meet people that I'm a fan of
'Cause I geek- I don't know how to act
I really don't
What do you bring to your characters, like your own personality
Well, Paul doesn't have a personality that really...
He's got the hair
for Paul
The hair
What do you guys bring to your characters?
I don't want to answer this question
Kat?
Well, not the fashion
I'm kidding
We have very different styles obviously
She's much more earthy and uhm...
Hippie
Bonnie's crunchy
Like Granola-crunchy
Like she's Granola
Spells, and...
like, sauces and shit
Yeah, that's more gummybear
I don't know
Definitely the determination
I'm hoping the loyalty, the kind of...
I don't know, what do you think Ian?
Bonnie and Kat are badass
They both want the best for the world and the people around them
They're super duper duper sincere and loving
Uhm
But
When you piss either one of them off
Run
That's accurate
Candice, what about you?
What do you feel like you bring to Caroline?
You are Caroline
She is Caroline.
I think she is
She is Caroline
The most likely character-
Am I?
I feel like maybe the party planning
And the, like, obnoxious
high pitched voice
stressful...
She's the same
Like all the obnoxious...
Blaah
No, you're, you're lovely
Oh, geez
Steroline! Stero- Sorry
She doesn't need you to tell her that
I'm probably the least like my character
I think
I am friendlier
And more, uh...
approachable
Probably
I don't know, man, Enzo's pretty damn approachable
I think you bring the animalistic side out of him
Before we do scenes, he always, like, stretches
He, like, warms up
Yeah, I have this kind of animal work-out thing
Well, not work-out
Animal work-out
I do kind of animal noises
Careful man, you're back in the US, that's illegal
To kind of loosen myself up
You know, sometimes, when you're doing a scene
you kind of realize you're kind of stuck in this one zone
you're playing it like a certain way
And for me, what helps is just to do something like
completely stupid, like
you know, like a horse noise
No, he literally
Yeah, he literally
That's awesome
And all was well
He does
He goes like this
He goes
Before his takes
Before he starts shooting
I can't do it right now
My voice is, like, 10 decibels lower than it was yesterday
Are you trying to sound sexy?
No, man
I'm just
I
My coffee hasn't kicked in yet
I think it was decaf
I don't know what's going on
Oh, did you get it from the one on the right?
That's decaf
Man, I don't know my right from left
It's uh...
None of these are an R!
Like, how are you supposed to figure that out?
God dammit
Malarkey just woke up
Thank you for your question
Hi
Hello
Hi!
I'm Alex
Hi, guys!
First of all, I love you
Ian, you have amazing eyes!
Love you, love you, love you!
Um
But
In one of the episodes we see Caroline
sing, and you're amazing!
Aw, thanks!
How was it?
And are we gonna see more?
I don't know if I'm gonna-
I was very surprised that I sang as much this year
Um
But
I was completely terrified
But it was pretty fun
Kind of felt like
We shot the, like, karaoke stuff very early in the morning
So, when
It's like
You know, seven A.M. on a Monday, and...
You're dancing around a Pat Benatar, up on a little crickety stage
You definitely feel like a-
You wanna sing right now?
No, I don't
Paul, thanks though
I really appreciate it
No, but thank you!
Thanks guys
After you, Paul
Uh
No
You don't want to hear me sing
But thank you
Thanks
Next question?
Hi guys, I'm Corina
And I'm Sofia
And our question is for you
Is, now that Elena's gone
How do you think the show's gonna change?
Things are really
gonna be fantastic
I'm just kidding
It was a joke!
Oh God!
They turned on you!
Headline
It's just an evolution of the story, guys
Everything changes
Stories come
Stories go
And this is evol-
This is an evolution of the story
This is Mystic Falls, without Elena Gilbert
And also
Yesterday
I mean, the fact is that she's not dead
And what's beautiful is that you still
feel the essence and, like, the spirit of Elena
As we come back into season seven
Ode to Elena
The writers did
You guys did a great job of incorporating that
I think that when a show is on for seven years
Obviously it was Nina's choice
It hasn't been on for seven years
Dude, it's been on for six years
It's literally
Oh, Lord
You act like my brother sometimes
No, it's, when a show has been on for seven years
Shut up
Um
You...
You know, Nina obviously decided to leave
Um
It's a...
It's...
It's kind of...
You need a shift in dynamic
And I think it created a new sort of swirl
In a way
And so, I think it's...
a fresh take on a show that's been on for over half a decade
You know what I mean?
Okay?
We've time for a couple more questions
There you are, kiddo, you're in the spotlight now, girl
Hi, I'm Samantha
And, just wanna let you know, I'm a huge Steroline fan!
Like, that's just what I need to happen!
I just wanted to know if you guys will be having , uh, the Pop Funko, any figures released?
For the show?
It needs to happen!
Those little collector items
That they make
Where do we get them?
What are they?
Are they bobbleheads?
I want one
What are they?
are they dolls?
the wobbly car head thingies
you guys are the worst
Oh yeah!
No! they're not- No!
they're just, like, little figures!
I feel old
We're gonna get right on that
I don't know what you're talking about, but that sounds great!
Yeah!
Pop Funko!
Let's do it
Very cute
This is gonna be our last question
So make it good
Hi
Hi, my name is-
They're ready for us to get off stage anyway
They're all waiting for something else
I'm a huge fan of you guys
And I was wondering...
What did you say?
Hi, my name is Alexis
Hi Alexis!
Um
I was wondering, what is your guys' favorite OTP
throughout the whole show
What's an OTP?
That would be a One True Pair
A one true pair!
One True pair
So who's your favorite couple on the show, of all times?
Hey, I was gonna start, dude!
Do it!
Go!
Denzo
Denzo!
Yeah
Gay marriage is legal now
Yeah, I love Denzo
I was gonna say Steroline
But now after seeing Kai and Damon
I don't know anymore
Kaimon!
Kaimon rules
Denzo
Amen
Stelijah
Elijah
Stefan
It's really more just
I really, really like Daniel Gillies
I'm very attracted to him
-You have a crush
Um, I'm Dalaric
All day long
absolutely
One hundred percent
Dalaric?
Damon and Alaric
Well, I guess that's the end of Denzo then
No
No, I love 'em all, man
Dalaric
Denzo
My boys
They're my boys
Now it's
Kaimon
I mean
These are my brothers
What if
Kai, Enzo and Alaric
Oh God
And Damon all got together
And just crushed a weekend in Vegas
That'd be a good episode
Would you guys leave the hotel room?
That's what I'm talking about
Sometimes there's no need to leave the hotelroom, doug!
Um, no, there have been so many incredible pairings and groupings and...
Ships, as we now call it
Um
That
I just, there's to many of them, there's six years of them
And I love them all
I'm grateful for all of them
Shut up Paul!
I would say, for me, it's Katherine and Stefan
Oh yeah
Um
I don't even know
Such a dangerous question
Um
Bonnie and Damon fucking rock
They do
They do really rock
Bonnie and Kai
Yeah, there's been some really fun stuff, I mean
You know, the show's-, there's so much
That goes on on the show
You know, from the action to the romance
And
Um
It's easy for people to just get so exited about all the ships
But it's, there's so many different dynamics on the show, so
It just depends on what mood I'm in that day
You know, if you kinda want that volatile thing, then you know
I really liked, um, ...
Um, I think the Katherine and the Damon-character
I think that was really cool for a while
I, I liked, um...
I liked Klaus and Caroline
I liked, yes
I mean, obviously Bonnie with everyone
I'm kidding
You know, I could go on forever
That's kinda the thing, It's that we all
adore working with each other so much
That we can't really differentiate
And for me, I joined late, and I feel
very
Um
Lucky and happy to be a part of this wonderful family, you know
And I feel like I've been welcomed in the family
Liv and Tyler
It's, I'll keep going if you want
Liv, Tyler, are you still going on? Sorry
Matt and Damon would make Matt Damon!
Matt Damon!
Is my mic on?
Sorry
I'll shut up
That's alright, cool
Guys, well, listen
Thank you so much for today!
Thank you for six amazing years
Very much looking forward to season 7
Thank you guys so much!
And thank you all so much for coming out today!
Thank you guys so so so much!